Narrator: PREPARING RICE
IN AN ELECTRIC COOKER
IS EASIER THAN COOKING RICE
ON THE STOVE.
YOU THROW IN THE RICE AND WATER,
PRESS A BUTTON,
AND WALK AWAY UNTIL IT'S READY.
THIS MACHINE IS DESIGNED
TO STEAM RICE TO PERFECTION.
RICE COOKERS USE INDIRECT HEAT
TO CIRCULATE STEAM
AROUND RICE AND WATER,
FROM THE OUTER POT
TO AN INNER POT.
THIS PROCESS COOKS THE RICE
EVENLY IN HALF AN HOUR.
TO CAST THE OUTER COOKING POT,
ALUMINUM INGOTS
ARE MELTED IN A FURNACE.
A ROBOTIC ARM SCOOPS UP
THE REQUIRED AMOUNT
OF MOLTEN ALUMINUM
WITH A LADLE...
...THEN POURS IT
INTO THE TOP OF THE MOLD.
IT TAKES THE METAL FOUR MINUTES
TO COOL AND SOLIDIFY.
THEN TECHNICIANS EXTRACT
THE POT FROM THE MOLD.
TO REFINE ITS FORM,
THE POT IS MOUNTED
ON A COMPUTER-GUIDED LATHE.
AS IT SPINS,
SEVERAL MACHINES CONTOUR
THE POT'S OUTSIDE SURFACE
TO ITS FINAL SHAPE.
♪♪
NEXT, THE POT IS LOADED ONTO
AN AUTOMATED DRILLING MACHINE.
THE MACHINE PUNCTURES 18 HOLES
THROUGH THE BOTTOM.
THE RICE COOKER'S
HEATING COMPONENTS
AND ITS PAINTED STEEL SHELL
ARE ATTACHED TO THE OUTER POT
THROUGH THESE HOLES.
THEN THE POT IS RETURNED
TO THE COMPUTER-GUIDED LATHE.
A TOOL POLISHES THE INTERIOR
UNTIL THE ALUMINUM
IS SMOOTH AND BRIGHT.
A DISK OF STAINLESS STEEL
IS PLACED IN A PRESS.
THE PRESS MOLDS THE STEEL
INTO THE INNER COOKING POT.
THE NEXT PRESS TRIMS OFF
ANY EXCESS METAL AROUND THE TOP,
LEAVING A CLEAN AND EVEN EDGE.
ANOTHER MACHINE CURLS THAT EDGE
TO FORM A ROUNDED LIP.
THE LIP STRENGTHENS THE POT
AND PROVIDES A PLACE TO GRIP
WHEN THE INNER POT
IS PLACED INTO THE OUTER POT.
ONCE POLISHED, THE POT
IS PLACED IN ANOTHER PRESS.
THIS PRESS STAMPS
WATER-LEVEL LINES ON THE SIDE
AND A TRENCH ON THE BOTTOM.
THE TRENCH HELPS THE WATER
EVAPORATE QUICKLY.
NEXT, AN AUTOMATED BOOTH PAINTS
THE RICE COOKER'S STEEL SHELLS.
THE SHELLS ARE BAKED IN AN OVEN
FOR 15 MINUTES
AT 390 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT
SO THAT THE PAINT CAN SET.
WITH A PAD PRINTER,
THE COMPANY LOGO
IS APPLIED TO THE SHELL.
TECHNICIANS INSTALL
PART OF THE SWITCH MECHANISM
TO THE SHELL.
ANOTHER TECHNICIAN PLACES
THE HEATING ELEMENT IN A SLOT
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE OUTER POT,
SECURING IT WITH THREE CLIPS.
THEY INSTALL
TWO CONNECTION PLATES
USED TO ATTACH
THE STEEL SHELL --
A PORCELAIN PLATE
AND A MAGNETIC CORE.
THE CORE CONTROLS
THE ON/OFF SWITCH
BASED ON THE TEMPERATURE
INSIDE THE COOKER.
♪♪
THE TECHNICIAN CONNECTS
THE POWER CORD
AND ATTACHES
THE THERMAL-INSULATION SHEET,
WHICH ALLOWS THE COOKED RICE
TO MAINTAIN A TEMPERATURE
OF 158 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
THIS PART
OF THE SWITCH MECHANISM
HOVERS OVER THE MAGNETIC CORE.
WHEN THE COOKING TEMPERATURE
HITS 158 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT,
THE CORE ACTIVATES THE SWITCH
TO TURN OFF THE HEATING ELEMENT
AND START UP
THE THERMAL-INSULATION SHEET.
AFTER MORE SWITCH WIRING,
TECHNICIANS INSTALL THE FUSE,
WHICH PREVENTS THE COOKER
FROM OVERHEATING.
ONE END IS CONNECTED
TO THE HEATING ELEMENT,
THE OTHER END TO THE POWER CORD
BY THE PORCELAIN PLATE.
THE PAINTED STEEL SHELL
IS ATTACHED
TO THE BASE OF THE OUTER POT.
ONCE ATTACHED,
EACH CONNECTION PLATE
IS SECURED WITH SCREWS,
THEN HANDLES ARE INSTALLED.
FINALLY, EVERY RICE COOKER
UNDERGOES A TEMPERATURE TEST.
AFTER STARTING THE MACHINE,
THE COOKING TEMPERATURE
IS MEASURED WITH A THERMOMETER.
ONCE APPROVED, THE COOKER
IS PACKAGED WITH A COVER
AND PERFORATED INSERT
FOR STEAMING OTHER FOODS.
TO USE THE COOKER, YOU PUT RICE
AND WATER IN THE INNER POT
AND WATER IN THE OUTER POT.
IN UNDER AN HOUR,
THE HEATING ELEMENT TURNS OFF,
AND THE INSULATION SHEET
KICKS IN TO KEEP YOUR RICE WARM.